once an Tian is a day laborer Thomas
idea
I worked there today so I have to work
if I don't work I won't have enough to
cover the basic necessities necesitas at
the nonprofit outreach center where
Santa Yan goes to find work
staff are preparing bags with soap
tissues and information packets about
kovat 19 we were really concerned
specifically for our workers that are
elderly we're really concerned about
them we like I said we have a huge
population of workers that are 60 and up
while at work many undocumented workers
can't even practice basic virus
prevention our workers who don't have
access to running water can't even wash
their hands at the Monsignor Oscar
Romero clinic in Los Angeles dr. Don
Garcia treats low-income families many
of whom are undocumented they live in
the shadows their exposure I could very
well say on an epidemiological site
could even be higher than the ordinary
resident or person of the United States
just because of their employment status
Garcia says some undocumented people
avoid interacting with public health
systems for fear of being caught by
immigration authorities and deported
doctors say if the situation remains in
which undocumented people stay in the
shadows away from the healthcare system
during the pandemic it poses a grave
risk to the population as a whole
they're becoming a transmission vector
to all those other individuals that they
are exposed to unless government policy
encourages undocumented people to come
out of the shadows the danger of
infection could increase for everyone
rob reynolds al jazeera los angeles